So I think today our goal is to really figure
out these image selections.
Based on the ones that you guys sent, I went
through and did a preliminary edit because
I think you sent about 22 and we can only
use maybe 15 to 16.
We put together all these group shots and
we started to feel like we needed some scale
shift, so I pulled some portrait shots as
well that we’re feeling like we kind of
want to mix in a combination of, you know,
maybe the primary players in the show with
these groups.
I don’t mind that idea, but if we do that
we need to be sure to mix the players more.
For sure, yeah.
So how do you feel about where we are right
now?
This is really just sort of an update from
last meeting where we wanted to confirm
a couple things just to make sure that we’re on the right track.
You know, the basic idea I like, but it looks
a little composed.
I think the bluing works against the excitement
of it.
So, what’s the positive?
Maybe we’re getting to the slightly scrappier
feel, maybe even shifting the colors among
the photos a little bit so some are maybe
more sepia.
I don’t know if that’s possible?
Maybe the clustering a little bit less like
a word cloud and a little bit more like it
is scattering the photos.
What about carrying the photos over?
Love that!
Did you want to see any more archival photos
from Made Thought just while we’re teaming
up?
I would love to see if you want to show us.
That’s a nice one of Cy Twombly.
What’s different between these two?
Well, he made an inventory of silk screens—about
120—and then he would recombine the images
in different ways.
So you know, you can imagine it’s trying
to think digitally before you have digital
capacity, so instead he has a stack of screens
and he can combine the screens.
That’s very cool.
Okay this is him…
This is nice!
What is he doing?
He’s taking paintings in Venice to install
at the Venice Bienalle.
Whoa, on a boat?
On a gondola.
That’s how you install art in Venice.
Beautiful, right?
Is that his island?
Yeah, that’s his island!
Okay, I think that’s where we are.
There are very few that if you look through
and think it might work that we would say no
to, so…
Great!